second scene right now because quite
frankly we don't get as much attention
uh compared to what a key got for us
back in evil japan so uh this is this is
a great this is a really good start for
us we just need to be
able to travel more frequently more more
tournaments you know big shout outs to
you guys thank you so much for providing
this for us it's a it's a great
opportunity so thank you so much
yeah tekken online challenge of course
you know i mean that's kind of the goal
right like everyone knows the world is
kind of locked down right now uh and
obviously the number of regions we just
saw on that chart a second ago uh this
is truly global you know there's there's
tournaments happening in africa uh in
different parts of africa you know all
across asia and north america etc etc
right so uh it's really wonderful that
the tekken online challenge has given us
opportunities to so many scenes uh
literally around the planet but it's
time guys for the grand finals rgn
versus ak ak on the winner side of
things out here sticking it out with
shaheed rgm bringing that akuma you know
ak used to use akuma so you know he's
gonna be well versed in the matchup
let's see what happens
game one
all right so ak
and the winner side huge advantage for
him
rgn gonna open things up with a down
four we know how effective that was
since the last game aka sidestep into
dash in into altair that's pretty damn
good
that was crazy oh my god god dude
bro his reactions are insane right like
he's been doing seismic downpour two all
day sidestep delay hopking
as a whiff punish
bro
he's playing next up that is a statement
for the grand finals right now
yeah for sure that is 88 second we are
seeing here boys and girls rgn's gonna
have to adjust to that let's see if ak
struggles the same way jules did in that
last game whether or not he can close
rounds out properly again we cannot
count rgn out considering what he showed
us earlier
bro his side step on the down for a
second ago was so incredible
like i was just
inaudible how do you do that
yo meter though you see combo
yeah that's right i'm gonna go for the
wall here big damage coming in from rgn
aka put that rage can he come back from
this down four to close things out here
we go
fight yeah and that's a great sign from
rgn right like ak's first i was so
dominant with these hop kicks and with
these delayed hopkins that it looked
like they were gonna fall apart key
charge set up time still key charge what
that that's wild like i'm curious what
like the best option kuma would be there
i can't believe that you can't believe
that ak did something again you know
what i mean if there's anyone going to
do something again it's okay
i never should have doubted it
oh my god ak is such a beast argento
still trying to
come back from this almost for that
range here
orbital can he close it out one more hit
our jam looking for the low parry uh
just a bit late the timing was off for
ak
and exact exactly what aka did there is
exactly what jules needs to do right
like just throw off your timing a little
bit and then do your low attack right
because it makes it much more
unpredictable like if you just run up
and immediately attack then it's just a
pure 50 50 right like they're gonna
probably fish for like a fuzzy low low
parry low block and stand again but if
you just stand there for a second then
also everything's out the window you're
just standing in pure neutral and then
they have to guess right so smart stuff
from ak there get in that first game and
you know he lost the second round but
every other round was just so dominant
uh in terms of you know his facing and
his punishment it's like he's like are
you gonna throw a fireball because if
you do i'm probably gonna size different
hopkins you know i'm gonna i'm decisive
and kill you in some way or another uh
maybe it might be a delay hopkin uh so
if i'm rgn i'm a little i'm a little
hesitant to throw out some fireballs
after that first game
and probably one of the most common
round enders also is you know the df1
mid check that's always a thing and the
generic down four yeah you know that was
a good choice for ak because as if i
remember correctly generic downforce
depending on where they came from like
from standing into like
from standing to a generic downfall
that's minus 13 if i remember correctly
but if it's if it's from a full crotch
that's launch punishable yeah did i get
that right
i don't know about the standing data but
definitely the full crash one is
launched punishable i think the other
one might be a little bit less i don't
know if it's minus 13 actually if it's
my 13 i've been punching it wrong for a
while i feel like anytime i block it
down for i always do while standing four
uh so it might be like 12 maybe it is 13
though somebody let me know in the chat
if you guys know
but here we go game two choose an
infinite stage here uh walls are
definitely factored but also switching
characters the devil gin comes out for
rgn
and starts things off with a hell sweep
also fearless that's what we call rgn
right now no matter what the situation
but ak does punish him with a sidestep
into the hopkick ak brings the damage
back
wow finishing laser scraper
i like that electric there
do it again
oh my god don't try to delay hot pick on
the cover
the counter hit into the guaranteed 2 3
ak so aware of the situation
yeah that counter head noise that comes
out is so loud like i think if you're
playing with sound like that's such a
big tell to easily counter confirm
yeah rgn there it is again the health
sweep but how long how many households
can you do against the guys a guy like
ak who can most likely guess what you're
what you're gonna do after uh afterwards
you know the bigger problem is you can
already see ak is side step left and
locking right he decides to let blocks
not have blocks so if there's a high
sweep coming right he's looking to step
it in the first place
one one two puts ak at rage now this is
a danger zone ak pulls the trigger on
the rage art but rgn was just psyching
him out the wave dash block and now one
round a piece
yeah it was pretty behind there pretty
uncharacteristic for me just kind of
give away around like that
uh but you know he was feeling it
four four over the slide that time
boom what a sidestep into electric rgn
ever so aware the execution is still
there aka with the orbital again can
anyone count how many he's hit
he's so good at it
because of this right he's breaking so
many damn legs everyone's like i can't i
need my legs underneath the orbital
these are new shoes man stop stepping
dude
punish that all right rgn looking good
in this game so far health is finding
its mark there
beautiful okay now our
rgn
trying to close this one out this is the
infinite stage so
a lot of movement gonna happen here
akito doesn't even look flustered about
what happened in the last few games
block and punish
yeah our gen doubleton is looking really
clean
this is such a surprise i didn't know
that he had a double jin but
you know it's kind of cool that he's got
both execution characters you know
okay here we go ak lower than half
health he's a few minutes if he's a few
hits away from getting rage here now he
does good low parry on the hell sweep
now what can he do to close this one out
go to the okay combo boy
hip-hop and ak closing this one out
taking it to a final round
yeah i mean that's really a bad call out
there with that spring kick and just
like that ak now could really turn
things around if he takes a 2-0 lead
here it's going to be rough for rgn
oh man
and ak really stepping up doesn't get
the delayed hockey
the pokes are so good it's adding up for
ak and rgn trying to make the right
guesses but he can't he wants delayed
hopkins so bad
yeah he's mighty
he's looking for it gotta be careful
about that devil gin rage driving us
down three
a.k.a so good with that aki's so good
that whenever he knows whenever he knows
that his opponent's gonna approach him
boom eat this uh eat this cut or boom
eat this down green he's so good with
that it's cool for me
that one was crazy because he actually
knocked him away then he did like four
backpacks it's usually a range where
you're looking at the screen you're like
okay there's nothing you can hit with
and ak knew that he gave me enough space
to hang himself so he's gonna dash and
he's not gonna expect me to dash forward
and reach out with his glow right like
he knew the range perfectly it was a
perfect bait closed out the game there
and ak now up 2-0 one game away from
taking the whole tournament here today
impressive man
i mean honestly impressive today
for sure aka really cementing the fact
that he is the best player here in the
philippines right now there is a reason
why we call him the top player here
alongside jules alongside maru and all
the other pros here in the philippines
guys he's here he's not here to make a
point he's just here to just remind us
all
yeah he's i mean regardless if he's
reminding you or not like it's always
good to have that player in any scene
that everyone can like strive to beat
right like he is the guy you know you've
got to beat ak to put yourself on the
board so you know all these players that
go up against them it's an opportunity
every single time to make a name for
yourself right uh and as aka being the
defender of that like that's pushing
yourself to be a better player as well
because you know everyone's gunning for
you right uh but here we go forgotten
realm great stage for devilgen as well
uh let's see if you can work on rgn's
favor
uh but you know shaheen is a monster and
ak has been absolutely ridiculous today
absolutely ridiculous
for sure i don't think you know i don't
think ridiculous is even enough to just
cover it all for how aka is playing
right now
argento gets oh gets buried in but he
does get the first uh floor break
wow interesting doesn't even decide to
do a screw attack there
[Music]
okay down back to
ak has him up against the wall oh that
could be so scary for rgn
keeping
he's going to look at that power
question again right or maybe a delayed
hopkick
you know he's looking for it does have
rage here arjun's gotta be super careful
here
don't be reckless don't make any mistake
don't whip on rgn did not press a button
yet again
round two man ak's wild dudes
oh my god
here to remind us he's here to remind us
bro
i've seen people online talking about yo
electric for cover too fast blah blah
start of the round delay hop kick the
whiff punish and electric bro that's
where ak's playing right now oh my god
and he lets it rip with the down back
two one also knowing rgn would press rgn
right now
i don't know what he can do here
he can help sleep
yeah more healthy
more floors
okay
oh gosh oh god out of that situation too
rgn was not expecting that now the
aggression is on ak plans on letting him
stay there one one two punish good but
that puts ak in rage rgn now he's been
in this situation but let's hit rip on
the hell sweep he's up two rounds
all right rgn
can still bring this back it's not over
until it's over
right the devils is definitely warming
up he's got the round count lead here
the movement the side stage was
definitely a good choice
yeah
rgn picked this stage it's good for
double gin um
okay
beautiful get him a little wave of
action hit back get the insta while
standing out of it got the while
standing too
uh and just like that he's on the board
two to one here it's not going to be a
sweep ak still has to fight to win this
tournament and now you know it gets a
little bit interesting right because
arjun he could still win the whole
tournament you know when he's when you
get in the grand finals you're this
position like oh i'm up 2-0 you you kind
of get the feeling that it's over right
but it's not it's not over until it's
over rj could still literally win the
entire thing which is the funnest part
about this to me uh and honestly the
diligent is looking sharper and i feel
like ak is already kind of showing him
everything that he can do right so now
it's all comes down to the mental game
uh about which we've seen time and time
again right like his ak gonna condition
him with the lows hit him with these
orbitals the side steps gonna meet up
for the downpour twos our slides gonna
come back you know there's a lot of
options here it's gonna be hard to stop
them but uh devilgen is a very very
strong character right now right and
we've seen the hell seasons and you can
see the health is starting to get the ak
that's why the wild sand two hits the
end there and the fact that rjn is now
bringing out that while standing too to
mix up with the whole suite means that
we're gonna have an interesting set next
game
and you know knowing ak's experience
he's probably only a little bit worried
about the mix-ups from the weibos into
the wall standing too he might even go
for the for the howard s estate here
which is his go to stage we'll see about
that
power to state
you called it
all right
potential tournament point for ak if you
could win this game
uh but i have a feeling
it's going down the final final i have a
feeling it just seems to always do that
attacking you know
for no reason whatsoever
man this stage is sick i love it one of
the coolest stages in the game
easily
all right here we go
okay
ak follows up with the combo key charge
set up oh no he doesn't go for it anyway
yeah he wants the bigger game yeah
oh boy
oh god
rga oh god is right
oh god
[Laughter]
ak looks like he woke up but he's like
i need to win this tournament
this is grand finals after all no duck
on a second hit but rgn does manage to
get a one one two in
slide mix-ups is rgn gonna
block any of those electric
i'm telling you the devil did's waking
up
[Music]
oh i love it no follow up on the combo
kind of airborne double just do it again
wall
oh good low kick solid low kick and just
like that it is tournament point for ak
god of this duck
nick the ak special let me see him key
charge set up okay he takes the steel
pedal instead goes for another slide
rjn trying to be more on the offensive
side but ak is denying the denying the
opportunity good block on the lows the
folks are coming up but rgn gets
stopping his tracks again one two two
he'll sweep coming in i feel it coming
what's he gonna do here oh man
slidy
what the
ak to close out the tournament oh let's
go it's not over
it's not over tournament point ah
rgn still alive here showing some signs
of life but ak still is up two rounds
ahead rgn's got a lot of work to do hell
sweet to go
and get some more momentum a lot of
damage coming in from rgm
good interrupt there what
confirm oh airport got him this time
and just like that ak is your tekken
online challenge 2021 champion for the
philippines at east age congratulations
ak three to one there over rgn nicely
done congratulations ak
yo
everybody make some noise for ak and
also rgn for making it this far
you know beating killers like maru and
jules that's not an easy feat so guys
make sure you give some praise also to
rgn this kid's got a lot to prove and
he's only getting better
amazing set